perfect thank you very much
i'll share my screen
cool yeah so
hello everyone i'm super excited to be
here today um
so thank you very much for the
introduction and the invitation
i see that there's a lot going on in
your community that's very nice to see
so today i'm going to give a talk about
dusk sql
a new python package in the das
ecosystem
which is a sql query layer for dusk
and so the first thing of course i want
to do is introduce to you what a sql
query layer is
and a bit then a bit about dusk and then
of course also what dusk sql
can help you with so
a bit about myself i'm nils hi
so i'm the developer of ts fresh and
thus sql ts fresh in case you don't know
it
is a time series feature extraction
library
also for python so you can use it for
automated feature extraction on time
series and also feature selection
um as erin said i used to work as a data
scientist now i'm a data engineer
so i know those two worlds and currently
i'm working at bosch
at the bosch center for artificial
intelligence and i'm a trainer for data
engineering there
so i will later also tweet about my
slides so if you want you can follow me
on twitter
and then also get the link to those
slides here and also the code that i
will show
yeah so let's introduce task sql
and sql query engines or query layers
so as i've heard you're coming from
different backgrounds which is super
interesting
and now let's maybe try to put ourselves
into the shoes
of this data analyst here so this data
analyst
has the job to analyze the data
of his company
and then also to apply transformations
and maybe machine learning to this data
and if you're now starting with a very
naive approach
this is actually quite complicated
because
if you're a data engineer you might know
the problem is you have data from
different data sources you have
data from sources that are very uncommon
maybe
inhomogeneous you have a lot of data
that you need to care about
and distribute computation is quite
complicated so maybe you want to start
quite simple and just ask your data
engineer well please give me the data
in excel files that might work
for some use cases but of course this
also has
quite many drawbacks so it's simple but
it does not scale very well
both in terms of data but also in terms
of iteration times whenever you want new
data you have to
go back to your data engineer again so
let's improve this
let's go to possibility number two we
asked now our data engineer for data
dumps in the database
this is much better because this might
even be automated an automated pipeline
there
to aggregate the data from the raw data
sources to the database
this time we can start to use sql
this is nice because sql is a language
that allows us to
translate our quite complicated queries
and complicated transformations into
something which is quite simple and we
can even use our bi tools for example
apache u or power bi or
metabase to connect to those sql
databases
and the problem is we can only put
aggregated data into this
sql database because typically you have
a lot of data
in your company and that this does not
fit well in this relational databases
and still if you want to have the
different columns
different data in your data dumps you
still need to go back to your data
engineer and ask
for updates
okay so let's also improve with that
we use a sql query engine
so what is the sql query engine um we
start again
with the raw data so when i say raw data
i actually mean
data stored on things like s3 in the
cloud
maybe on hdfs hadoop distributed file
system or could even be
local disks in your cluster
and this data is distributed among many
machines
because it's big data because it's
complicated data
and that's why on top of that we took a
distribute we put a distributed
computation engine
that could be things like spark could be
things like mapreduce
or later we'll see that could also be
dusk
and then we we use a cluster maybe a
kubernetes cluster
or a cluster in the cloud to distribute
this computation
what writing and maintaining those
distributed computations
this is complicated this is hard so
that's now the point where sql query
engines enter the game
they are something like a layer on top
of the distributed computation framework
and they translate sql from the user
into those complicated distributed
computation
so for example you might have heard
about hive impala or presto
they are all sql query engines and they
use the sql
from the user and then give this to the
distributed
computation engine on the cluster so you
can query the data with sql now and also
if the data is a lot
you can still use sql that's super nice
and it still connects with your bi tools
and you can really leverage the full
power of your cluster this is very good
now unfortunately there's still a
drawback
and this drawback is that these are
typically java
applications so they do not connect well
with
the data scientists world so for example
things like machine learning or maybe
just if you have
certain transformations already coded in
in python
it's very hard to use them in those sql
query engines
and they are built for the usual data
formats
like parque or csv files but if you have
a more complicated data format
um they don't play very very well
okay so what do we do
well we just use python as a sql query
engine
and so the the concept is still the same
but this time
we use a python framework for our
computation
and this python framework is of course
dusk
in a few slides i will tell you more
about that what does this
um but there are three sql query engines
uh
around um probably even more but at
least three that i am aware of
one is stars sequel one is blazing
sequel and one is fugue
the idea in the sequel for example is
really
use the sequel from the user as a string
then parse it does sql is using apache
calcite for that but
it doesn't really matter at the end the
sql get passed
and then it to python code
and this python code is then executed on
the cluster
and can access similar to other sql
query engines the data on your
distributor storage like s3 hdfs
or things like hive
so i did mention dust now so let's let's
introduce it
task is similar to spark for the java
world
and a distributed engine it helps to
scale up your python code
because it integrates very well with the
rest of the python ecosystem
and especially the numeric python
ecosystem things like pandas or numpy
so the first code example you can see on
the left side
python code to read in a csv file and
then do some
some grouper and some aggregation but on
the right hand side you can see the
corresponding
task code it looks quite similar and
that's of course for a reason
but there's really a large difference
between those two uh
code examples the left one the pandas
one
runs on your single machine just in your
local machine
and the right one can scale to the full
cluster that you have
so das gives you the opportunity
to use those so called high level view
so you can create data frames you can
create something like distributed lists
you can create arrays and do
calculations on them
with the api that you probably know from
pandas or numpy
but using distributed distributed
calculations
does come also with a low layer
distributed engine which means it comes
with a scheduler it comes with
means to distribute certain functions um
to your cluster if you want to really
dig deep into the into your your
distributed computation
and that also helps other packages for
example here
you see it has integration with xg boost
that's the second code example
but also integrates very well with sql
sqlearn
the things like keras tensorflow pie
charge so
there are integrations and combinations
uh with dusk
and last but not least it also is the
basis for rapids the rapids ecosystem
and help scale them um to larger
clusters of gpus so it can also be used
in gpu calculations with the rapid
ecosystem
so task allows us now to keep
the python ecosystem that we love and
also integrate
uh the things that we use every day like
uh
cycler or extreme boost and still
have a distributed engine to run our
calculation
[Music]
in the cloud or on a cluster
and the way it works is shown here in
this this graph
it starts with those high level
collections like data frames
and out of the things that you do with
the data frame for example you do a
group buy you do some aggregation
it creates a task graph so
in this task graph it specifies
what should be done on the data so
whenever you call a group by
or a mean on your data frame in panda in
dusk
it will actually not do the calculation
right away but it will
create this task graph where you have a
node where it says
build the mean simplified
and this task graph is then sent to the
cluster and distributed among the the
machines
and that's the reason why dust can scale
so well
to a large number of machines
now we have a mean to
use python as a sql
query engine and what
what's now the benefit of that well the
benefit is that you can
use in the same code both the python api
that you know from pandas so quite
similar to pandas
and also sql so you can do some
transformations which are easier to do
in pandas
with the pandas api in python and then
you can just
mix them with sql statements so here in
the code example you can see some things
which are quite similar to
to uh to pandas so this reads cc here
for example
but then you can also see um there's a
there's a sql statement in between
that does some some aggregations in
group by and it will come to
the the api of the sql in a minute
i just want to say of course you can
also use it like your normal sql query
engine so in the background you can see
this is apache u one of these bi tools
which are used heavily
also in the in industry and this
actually has a
dust sql integration so you can you can
write
go ahead start apache u and connect to
your dusk sql cluster
so let's summarize that um with a python
query engine and dash sql would be one
example for that
you can still use sql but you can also
connect with your
the rest of the python ecosystem for
example with for machine learning or
other integrations
the drawbacks of the sql in particular
is does sql is still a very young
project so i really need to say this
it's it's super young it's just a few
months old
and it's definitely not battle tested
compared to those other sql query
engines
and that's also reason why just a part
of sql is implemented so far
but it's open source so always happy for
contributions of course
um i did mention that there's not just
dust sequel
um so does sequel is one python sql
query engine but there's also blazing
sequel
and fugue there was a talk on blazing
sql in the past
also in this pi data
meetup so let me quickly quickly repeat
what blazing sql does
blazing sql is a sql query engine built
for gpus
so it only runs in gpus but it is really
as the name
says blazingly fast so the use case
would be
if you have a lot of data that you want
to run on and you have access to large
gpu cluster
[Music]
the nice thing is that blazing sql
actually shares its api
with dash sql so we collaborated on that
so you can really switch between those
two for example if you
want to test something local you can use
dust sql if you want to test something
on your cpu cluster you can use task sql
and if you then want to go really really
big and have access to gpus you can just
switch this to place and sql and go
ahead
and yes they have a cool logo on that
sequel still does not have one
and then there's fugue um i'm not sure
if everyone knows already about fugue
so i learned just recently about it um
fube tries to build um
yeah a common framework for sql
and also non-sql python code to run
on dusk or spark or native backend so
you can
you can just switch the back end and
your code stays the same and then the
the calculation runs on dusk or in spark
or or natively on your local machine
so i'm currently collaborating with the
fugue authors
um to really get dust sql as the as the
sql backend for dusk and fugue but
that's really
a cool project so here's a um here's a
code example for that
uh for from fugue so this has nothing to
do with star sql but about fugue
and so it's actually using that sql in
the background
but what you see here is it's kind of
sql code
so you have your select statement here
um but it also has
variable assignments so you can assign
um
your select statements to variables and
then use those variables here
and you can also for example introduce
those python functions
and by just switching this task
execution engine
to a spark execution engine this code
will run out of the box on spark which
is which is cooling
really nice and of course it has all the
nice things like
you can you can load data and store data
and yeah use use basically everything
you know also from sql
okay so um let me go sorry
uh one one back uh so again
[ __ ] you can use it for
if if you want to switch between task
and spark
and it also uses that sql in the
background but if you want to stay local
and and you have access to maybe a das
cluster
you can also use star sql because it
also has some some nice things that we
will later see
also in the demo
all right that's actually already time
for demos
so um we actually do have one question
neil is actually if you want to
answer it before the demo yeah ravi was
asking um
will das equal need to be installed on
every worker node
on a hadoop high or hive data lake for
it to be used in the distributed
computing environment
that's a very good question so uh
actually no
so does sql only needs to be installed
on on one machine where you
where you can connect to so um das sql
has both as i said it has a
sql interface so it's just a port it
uses the presta protocol to speak with
your bi tool
so you only needed to have this server
run once
or if you just use it from your local
computer from your jubilee notebook i
don't know
just need to have installed there so
what will do it will parse the sql
and then we'll send just a dash
computation graph
this task graph that i was talking about
to the cluster
so on those worker machines does sql
does not need to be installed
they don't know that the statements come
from sql they just see the dust
publication graph and do their normal
stuff as you would
call if you just like
code df.group something like this
that's really cool and that's handy
especially if people have like big
clusters already set with environments
you just have to install it on your
client
uh uh there is one more question
um from michael is the api for das
versus blazing the same
as if like you would swap imports or is
the same
or is it the same api with like a common
set of interfaces
um it's it's the like the swap import
thing
so um yeah maybe we'll see later in the
demo there's a context object
in the sql and there's a context object
in
uh blazing sql and they do share the
same api
so if you have code that that once you
do it does something with this context
object
they could just switch this from from
blaze and sql or to to
sql but um uh
yeah that's that's the what what happens
in the end is actually quite different
they both use apache held side but then
latin sql
uses cuda c plus bus code to do the
calculations
and basic and does sql is using das
python code to do the do recalculations
all right
more questions if not i will switch the
demo but of course
feel free to just yeah ask more
questions if you want
okay is this large enough should i maybe
zoom in
to the notebook we first will just need
the notebook
okay it looks good looks good on my head
very good
so i just spin up here
in jupiter lab with a with a jupiter
notebook here
and what i did i start with some imports
um so dash sql as i said it has this
context object
and the reason for having this context
object is this is basically where you
store
and register the tables that you have so
everything in sql is around
tables so you need to tell the sql when
i say
table table a then i speak about this
amount of data and these things in these
columns
that's the reason for this context what
i also did i
i spin up a local
dust cluster so if you have never heard
of task
just just yeah you can just keep it as
it is
and if you know about us then you
probably know that you can very easily
switch this
to connect to connect to your um
cluster to your um cloud
cluster or maybe your kubernetes cluster
or things like this but here i just have
a local cluster
running with just four workers and on
the right hand side here
you see the the cluster dashboard
uh which basically yeah can say tell us
later what is going on in our cluster
so here's the first uh sequel that i
will call uh
this evening it's just a method of the
context
and you can just give it the the sql
code
and what we'll do it will send this
calculation the cluster will
okay this is very easy convention
there's actually no nothing going on
here
because just the constant and it will
return us
a pandas data frame in this case but if
you
turn this to true which is the default
it will return us a dash data frame
which is
still this computation task graph that
you can then send out to your cluster
so this computation has already happened
on the cluster
and the next code is just for uh for a
bit better visibility
so that i can just write um sql here as
a shortcut
and it will do exactly the same thing as
here and this is the
thing that i will use in the following
again i'm now showing you the python api
but you can do the same things also from
your
bi tool and just do those sql
select calls directly um to your sql
server
okay so when we want to do something on
data we first need data so we need to
import data
and there's three methods to do this um
in that sql the first thing is you start
with a dash data frame so maybe you have
already a dash data frame
maybe you create one by reading data
from csv so here i'm using of course the
iris data set
i guess you all know it and i'm
i'm creating a new data frame out of
that
and as i said the data frame
is really similar to pandas data frame
so here's the head method
and it will show me the first 10 10
lines um
so i guess you know we have these
different species here
of iris flowers and then we have some
features of that
and now we just need to tell the sql
that we actually
have this table and we want to give it a
name and this is
done with this create table method here
and from now on whenever i say iris in
my sql statements then
the sql knows aha i'm referring to this
data frame here that i have registered
there
you can store the same thing directly
from sql
so um there's a create table
method in das sql
uh i just give it the same name and then
say
tell it okay use this file location
format csv
and also persist it which means cache it
the nice thing is here again it's python
it's dust
so you can immediately use the very huge
dash ecosystem for that so dusk has
integrations for
s3 for uh many things on the
on the azure ecosystem also now coming
ray knows about it uh hopefully uh soon
dbfs so databricks file system
google storage hdfs a lot of other
things
you can connect to your hive cluster you
can hopefully soon connect your
databricks cluster you can connect your
intake catalog
so as the python ecosystem is so large
this is really
immediately here available to you
and last but not least you can as you
can do in many
sql engines also
yeah create those materialized queries
so from one statement
you can create a table maybe like as a
shortcut and i will use this a lot in
the following
and here you see there was actually
something going on but there was really
just a small look up so
not a lot on our cluster so far
yeah two small helper methods uh
it has the typical sql methods uh
implemented
you can list the tables so we have two
currently
you can list the columns of the table so
it's the same information again but
quite useful if you
only have the sql interface to that
okay to showcase you what does sql can
do i will just
um show you a few quite simple
sql statements so as i said that sql
tries to
implement a lot of sql but sql
unfortunately is quite large
um so there's a lot of translation that
needs to be done
but a large fraction is already
implemented so
of course you could do the quite simple
select statements here
the first 10 items you could do more
complicated things like
you can add two columns you can give it
a different name
you can call the sinus on the pedal
length
although that probably doesn't make
sense a lot
that will work and here the right hand
side you can see whenever i
issue such a command there's a small
calculation going on on our cluster
not a lot because all the data is of
course very small in this case
you can do group bias and aggregations
um and this one is a bit
it's more to do and you can also do
quite complicated things so if you know
sql
maybe you're quite quite fast here um
there's one table defined maximum values
which is just the maximum
species sorry the maximum steep length
per species
and then i collect here
all those values where those maximum
where the stable length is actually
maximal
so i do a join here and the group by
and all of this runs on the sql
if you're interested what happens behind
that there's an explain method
and it will basically tell you um
what it will do so this statement here
was given to apache health site and a
calcite gives us this
um this nice output here which basically
tells us what do we need to do
one after the other so it starts from
the from the bottom
it starts with the table iris then it
does a project which means it
only gets certain columns of that and
then does it aggregate and so on and so
on
and the job of that sql is basically
just to translate those calls
into das api icons
okay so now so far everything
is quite standard so most sql query
engines can probably also do that
now to the things that that really
are good when you have a python sql
query engine and that is you can use
your python functions
so maybe you have a complicated
transformation function
so here i have a function to calculate
the volume
which is not so complicated probably i
can do this also in sql
or just to showcase here um so i have a
python function i register it as
at my context um i need to give it some
type information because sql is a type
language
so i need to tell it that i i have loads
as the return type and also expecting
floats as my input parameters
and from that on i can use this iris
volume that i've registered here
and as everything is python there's
really no no drawback
no performance penalty here um
so there's no translation happening this
really is calling the python function
and inside this python function you can
do whatever you want so you can even put
in i don't know
an api call or maybe connect to your
second data source which is not handled
able to handle in sql
things like this or
you can put in machine learning into
those functions
so in principle you put here in this
return function
just call your psychic learn model or
tensorflow model
and get the prediction and then use this
directly in your sql statements
and aggregate and do some calculations
and as this is such a common pattern
here
and this is actually already built in
directly into the
sql so um here
we have a bit more complicated um
[Music]
sql statement um so i want to do machine
learning
so i have to start with feature
engineering
i will create um one
one new table here called enriched iris
and um i will use the columns from
before the
simple length the width the petal length
and width
and also my volume that have that i've
calculated before
and i will turn my um my species into a
[Music]
integer so zero one or two
so now i've done feature engineering so
if you want to have a look select star
from
my enriched iris
limit 10
you go so i have the same columns as
before
plus my additional volume here
and now the next step in machine
learning is of course i
want to do a trade test split so i'm i'm
using a table sample
sql method here which in this case
splits it at 50
and i'm storing this in the training
data
and so the training data looks like this
now it's uh shorter than the the full
data and it's also
um shuffled a bit and now i can
train a machinery model on top of that
so there's a
sql statement it does sql which is
called create model
and i can just give it um a reference
to a python method so
a python a normal python machine
learning model
so i'm using an xg boost machine
learning model here the xgb classifier
i tell her that i have three classes and
i tell her that i need
it to train on the species um
column and that's it and what it will do
in the background now this one is a bit
more complicated of course this
calculation
it will fetch the data and it will then
send the data
to the classifier and as this everything
is python it will it will work out
nicely so i can now predict with this
model
um so i predict with this created model
here
this is my model and using
my full data sample and this will look
like this
so i end up again with the same columns
but now there's an additional one
which is called target and this is now
the output of my prediction
and for example i can now start to um
see how how well the method did so for
example i can
create a temporary results table with
this these inputs
and now i don't know aggregate
on the species and count how often i
have seen which
which predicted label so this is the
result
so here's you see what was the real
species
yes you see the the predicted label and
you see
it's not a one-on-one uh correspondence
so probably not
super well trained but this is just an
example
and again this is python so this is a
pandas data frame so you can use
smartphone
to just plot what the output here
and um see directly the distribution of
those
um yeah of those target variables and
and trained variables
so this is really the nice thing you can
mix and match
python code with sql code and basically
use them vice versa
in in the in the others
okay um so this is already the end of
the demo
i have intentionally used um
my local machine here because uh i don't
want to trust
the the cloud for it for this demo but
by just switching the local cluster to
your distributed cluster
this will scale to a lot of machines and
to a large data sample
um if you want other questions to the
demo
so i see that there are some coming up
in the
chat yeah there's uh one question
um that is it possible to query data
stored in
no sql databases ichi cassandra
yeah very good question so in the end as
long as there's a dust integration for
that
you can basically use it directly from
um
[Music]
from dust sql so for example i'm not
sure about cassandra but i know that
there's
an elastic search integration just to
give an example for nosql databases
elasticsearch das integration
so you can turn elasticsearch data into
your dash data frame and then
you can also use this in your sql
gotcha nice um there's another question
here i think related to
the machine learning capabilities in
desk sql um
somebody's asking about like hyper
parameter tuning uh didn't see any of
that
in the sequel does it support that or is
it on the roadmap
so um thus sql supports machine learning
really from the
release which was released i think yeah
i released it two days ago so it's super
new
um but um i definitely want to improve
on that so definitely want to
put more more features in there so the
syntax is already similar to google's
bigquery
syntax and they have also subjects for
hyperparameter tuning
and dusk has a lot of yeah a lot of
packages for hybrid perimeter dreams so
it's not implemented so far
but that would be a very nice feature
addition yeah
cool another question uh comparing
like desk sql and blazing sql um
you mentioned like you know it can be
faster somebody's asking if gpus are
really helpful
for a sql query engine
so i did not but the blaze and sql guys
they did
but of course that might be a bit biased
um so um they have some very impressive
numbers
um so that you can also find on there on
their website
um and i did not
so far test with the same amount of data
um
and on large clusters but in general
um they did really well in implementing
those aggregations or calculations and
they are really fast
but if you want to scale too many
machines and for example also to
like very inhomogeneous clusters
then dust is really better and shines
that makes sense definitely uh i raised
asking something that i was actually
curious about too
is how would people want uh if people
wanted to get started and get involved
helping out with desk sql
uh where's the best play to get started
yeah so i do have still
like three slides and this i will cover
there
getting ahead uh i i actually did have
one question um
like related to like building and
developing this project you mentioned uh
apache calcite is used for like the the
sequel translation
um was that like a decision from the
beginning or did you try kind of
thinking about writing the translation
yourself and then moved over to there
how did that go
very good question so let me just scroll
up a bit um to the
output of basically apache car side
now that was too much um
so when i when i
started with with that sql um
as i said in my like a free time project
i actually thought well sql is not so
hard to understand so that should be
quite easy to write a parcel for that
and passing sql is not explicitly the
problem
the problem is that you can do a lot of
optimizations
even already on the sql code
um for example by only calculating
the same calculation once so
in this join here i might reference
the same thing that i have in my select
call here
and and these things and i don't want to
calculate them twice of course
things like this or there's a lot of
optimization going on
how do i join uh two things together and
these are things which are
already built in in apache health side
so that's why i
quite quickly moved to apache car site
also blazing sequels using apache
culture so that's
how i learned about that and they do a
lot of optimizations already there's
more things that could be done here but
um
they already built a quite optimized
graph which i then just need to
translate
awesome and it's great that i built the
project to be pluggable to yeah they're
super nice
um i mean it's java but they're also
like
java python integrations so jpipe
i use here and it works quite well
and then that again only needs to be on
your client right you don't have to if
you don't if your workers don't have
java then you get one
yeah yeah yeah uh looks like we've got a
couple more questions
um bob's asking does the create table
function copy data
uh is one and then how does dask sql
handle shared slices within data frames
so the create table function does not
copy data
so everything it does is basically a
reference to this
task graph so das only stores
information
i do have data and i have these column
names and with this type
but it does not fetch the data so far so
also does sql only handles these these
references to the data
and only when you basically hit the
compute button it will start to
go to your data and do the calculation
if you want as i have done so when i
created the first one
here you can tell das to cache the data
so then it will start loading it into
memory but this is not mandatory
and then the second question was how
does does sql handle shared slices
within data frames
so i guess you mean exact partitions
so this is handled by das so dusk
parallelizes via those partitions so it
splits up the data into different
chunks and then runs the calculation on
on those chunks and
thus sql using das does the same
great uh there's a question here about
integrating with like deep learning
frameworks like tensorflow krs um
is it possible even though the deep
learning is potentially done outside of
desk sql
so in principle
whenever you have a machine learning
model which
has the same api as the second learn so
i could learn as the
estimators you can in principle use this
directly in that sql
um probably you don't want to do that
because deep learning frameworks tend to
have a lot more options that you want to
tune maybe you also
want to tune how you train exactly um
how your
optimization is so probably you want to
maybe prepare your data and dust sql do
some
pre-aggregations and then use the output
the dash data frame or maybe even turn
this into a panda setting frame and then
does do the calculation in your deep
learning framework
that makes sense uh anybody else have
any questions adam in the chat
not i would show my last few slides
um some more links and then
we're done okay anybody has any last
minute ones get your questions in and
then
neil's going to answer them before we
before we break
okay so that one is over um so let me
just summarize what we've seen
dust sql is really as the name
says it's dust on the right hand side
and sql on the other side
so das means scaling python
so we can directly use the large
ecosystem
of open source data tooling
python many well-known tools for example
in machine learning
and it's the same time distributed
so i'm and the sql part
means opening the base to many
applications
as sql is heavily used for data analysts
which might not even know python they
can now start
using the python ecosystem with that and
it also connects with many different
applications
so as aaron said i'm i was working as a
data scientist and data engineer
so this is really nice because it
simplifies the collaboration between
data analysts data scientists and data
engineers
if you want to start using it here are
some links
so there's documentation up and
down sql itself is really just a contact
package you can install it with conda
or pip if you want but i would recommend
conda because of the java dependencies
and if you're new to dusk then there's
also a lot of dash documentation here
so they also have very nice
documentation up and running and there
also
had some medium articles which explain a
bit of an introduction and also how you
would deploy a dust sequel on a larger
cluster with kubernetes for example
there's also a cold article
and as you've seen i mentioned other
sql engines like blaze and sql and fuch
and they also
are linked here yeah so
um that was my talk very happy for all
of those questions and thank you very
much for listening
um yeah if you have more questions i'm
happy to answer them now
thank you very much news i definitely
learned a lot and i i think the format
of the talk was great the demo was
really
concise um we have one more question
um the question is asking specifically
about if desk has something
similar to like hyper opt and spark but
i kind of maybe will make that a little
bit more broad
because there's hyperop there's optuna
hyperband
like desk has its own stuff you know you
know what does kind of the integrations
look like their hyperparameter
so ray already mentioned dust of tuna
um which is uh like the
the integration of obtuna into dusk so
i'm actually not probably not the best
person to ask about all of those
libraries because i was not sure of um
know all of them um yeah so maybe if
someone in the chat can can answer
about those but i know that that some of
them have definitely does integration
yeah and i i'm in the same boat i know
some of them and not all of them so i
wouldn't want to answer too much i know
das also do
does have some native hyper parameter
tuning solutions like grid search and
randomized search
um inside of it as well
so there's also a question on the link
so here
shared also here that's a link to the
slides
great any final questions before we wrap
up
um if anybody wants to keep chatting
feel free to jump over to one of the
sessions
um i know a couple of the miami
attendees expressed oh wanted to hang
out a little bit after so feel free to
jump back into the sessions after this
but um if anybody
doesn't have any more questions um i
think we'll go ahead and wrap it up
thank you again so much niels for the
talk um i think this is great um
we'll have the recording available in uh
probably just a couple days and we'll
have that posted but
thank you all for joining too and have a
good weekend
thank you bye bye